[Музика]
добре, хлопці, я дуже радий бачити вас
сьогодні, як ви, я добре,
мене звати панна Ольга, і я вчитель
у гімназії плюс,
тому сьогодні ми поговоримо про спорт
подивіться, тож ви займаєтесь спортом
я особисто обожнюю спорт
я тренуюсь три чи чотири рази на тиждень мій
улюблений вид спорту кросфіт ви можете побачити
мої фотографії там це я під час моїх
перших ігор CrossFit минулого року, які
види спорту ви любите дивитися особисто мені
подобається  як дивитися фігурне катання та,
звичайно, кросфіт, чи можете ви помітити мого тренера,
він обидва на фотографіях, добре, це
той, щоб грати чи займатися спортом,
нам потрібно обладнання та місце, подивіться
інші слова з Богом, щоб ми отримали
Б'юся об заклад, це довга дерев’яна палиця, щоб грати в
ігри з м’ячем, а потім корт, це місце,
де, наприклад, ми граємо в інші
види спорту з м’ячем, а потім є поле або
поле, а я чув, що десь в
Англії, а потім рукавички,
що таке рукавички, рукавички є
захисними  речі, які ви використовуєте в
інших видах спорту  гольф, це вид
спорту, катання на ковзанах я люблю кататися на ковзанах
взимку, я розлютився, у світі так багато
хороших сечів, але, звісно,
краща книга про те,
як ми качали, басейн — це місце, де ми гойдаємося і р
корд  ви використовуєте його, щоб грати в
інші види спорту з м'ячем і трек,
ви любите швидкість, то мототрека
- це те, що вам дійсно потрібно,
добре, тож давайте помістимо слова в
пропуски в цій таблиці, щоб з Богом у
першому стовпці погано все було зроблено  обладнання
та місце в порядку, тому перша лінія
футболу Великобританії та футболу для США  тож
нам потрібен м'яч і куди ми розмістити
я думаю, що це правильно,
не вдалося або подача добре, давайте продовжуємо, тому у
нас є теніс
, це його для нього, яке обладнання нам
потрібно, щоб грати в теніс, подумайте трохи правильно,
що це рекорд і  Звичайно, ми граємо в
теніс на корті, тоді хм, цього виду
спорту немає, але у нас є клуб, і
курс спорту, який грають з клубом,
право, тобто гольф, плавання для
плавання,
нам потрібна кепка та окуляри, гм, але куди
ми ходимо плавати  ми ходимо плавати в
басейн, тож приходить бокс, ти
особисто фанат боксу, але все-таки
я дуже пишаюся українськими боксерами, тож
яке спорядження для цього нам потрібні рукавички
та ринг, щоб займатися боксом, потім йдуть
автогонки так  для автоперегонів нам потрібні машини
і куди ми можемо поїхати на автоперегони подумайте трохи
правильно
, це вантажівка, тоді баскетбол ви
любитель баскетболу, тому вам потрібна чаша, і
вам потрібно йти на корт,
хм, як у тенісі, цікаво тоді, якщо у мене
є ковзани  і перстень, що я буду
робити добре, я йду  g катання на ковзанах це
правильно,
тоді бейсбол не типовий вид спорту для
України, так що мені потрібно, щоб грати в
бейсбол
мені потрібно поле і ставка і
останній скін для катання на лижах звісно, вам потрібні ли
і і вам потрібно йти в роздратований це
р
вильно  добре, давайте йти далі і подивимося, що спорт
неможливий без людей,
які є людьми в спорті, ось
завдання, яке ви маєте зіставити слова та
визначення, чи не могли б ви спочатку
прочитати слова першим суддя тренер
тренер менеджер капітан глядач  і
суперник, учасник зараз, витратьте хвилинку
і перегляньте визначення, щоб
змагатися з іншими людьми, контролювати
місце спортивного матчу проти тренувати команду,
що це просто спорт, і я думаю, що
ви готові до матчу добре, тому
перший суддя, який  арбітр чи ви
правильно зрозуміли, що арбітр - це
людина, яка контролює спортивний матч і
приймає рішення, дуже важлива людина
у футбольному матчі, тоді тренер я знаю,
що тренер - це диван я знаю також,
що тренер  це зручний автобус, але тренер
– це також той, хто правильно
тренує команду для фітнесу та навичок, добре,
тоді ми підходимо до менеджера, чому спортсменам
потрібен менеджер, ну давайте подивимося, що
б ви вибрали, яка правильна
відповідь, правильно, що менеджером є той,
хто  організовує команду і вирішує
тактику, потім приходить капітан, я знаю,
що капітан у футболі має
спеціальний знак на рукаві, хм, що
він робить, або вона може бути
капітаном, ви зрозуміли, давайте подивимося, як правильно розрахувати
команду  поле або поле і, звичайно,
він лідер або вона
лідер команди, тоді глядач без глядачів неможливий спорт
без глядачів ми всі
хочемо дивитися якісь змагання ми всі
хочемо дивитися кубки і всі ми хочемо
підняти настрій свого улюбленця  команди, то хто
є глядач, глядач – це той, хто
дивиться спортивну подію, що правильно, добре,
давайте перейти до суперника в ігрових видах спорту
неможливо грати поодинці, тому
хто суперник, тоді суперник
той, хто грає знову
Особисто мені подобаються сильні
супротивники, а останній – конкурент,
і у нас залишився лише один варіант, щоб
конкурент змагався з іншими людьми
в перегонах або змаганнях, ми всі можемо бути
конкурентами в змаганнях, тому давайте
рухатися далі  тепер у вас є ті самі слова,
і ви повинні розмістити їх у
правильні пропуски, давайте переглянемо слова ще раз,
тому я суджу когось, хто
судить тренера, того, хто робить вас
менеджером, когось, хто організовує
все, що вам потрібно, щоб бути хорошим спортсменом
капітан хтось, хто веде вас у
команді, потім глядач, хтось, хто
приходить дивитися на вас під час змагань і
підбадьорити вас суперник людина, яка
грає проти вас, потім конкурент, ви
можете бути конкурентом, якщо ви змагаєтеся
в грі, тому зараз завершите  речення
переглядають перше речення добре,
тож давайте подивимося правильно,
менеджер вирішив перевести одного зі
своїх гравців в іншу команду привіт давайте
подивимося на друге речення, яке
команда не виграє  він зіграв перед 40 000
правих глядачів, а наступного
Джека запропонували цю посаду
в баскетбольній команді середньої школи,
можливо, це правильний тренер, тоді часто 95
хвилин та сигналізував про кінець матчу,
хто може бути, що, звичайно, це
арбітр, а потім усі  був здивований,
коли тренер обрав Теда
правильним капітаном команди, і понад 2000 брали участь
у Нью-Йоркському марафоні, хто вони
правильні своїх конкурентів, і останнє
речення тенісист легко переміг усіх
і виграв турнір, тож кого
він переміг його  переміг усіх своїх опонентів і
виграв турнір, це правильно,
хлопці, давайте йти далі, можливо, ви
помітили, що іноді я кажу,
наприклад, плавати, але я кажу грати в
баскетбол або якщо говорити про карате,
то чому нам потрібно використовувати різні
дієслова, щоб говорити про  різні види
спорту подивіться перший, який ми використовуємо, це
індивідуальні види спорту, якими ви можете займатися
поодинці, до речі, я обіймаюся життям, більшість
із них займаються
полюванням, наприклад, плаванням  біг підтюпцем
Кінг, і якщо ви бачите, що це енергетичний
кінець, це означає, що вам потрібно використовувати go,
давайте подивимося на приклад, ти
хочеш зі мною бігати підтюпцем чи це
інший думає про твій, можливо, тобі сумно
, ти хочеш піти  плавати зі мною або
ти хочеш зі мною покататися на лижах, можливо,
щось подібне, тоді друга
гра, яку ми використовуємо з командними видами спорту, або
інший лайфхак, якщо тобі потрібен бик,
тобі точно потрібно буде грати,
наприклад, хочеш грати  футбол зі
мною, до речі, я не граю в футбол,
хм, але мені подобається дивитися футбол,
і останній ми також використовуємо з
окремими бойовими видами спорту,
наприклад, ви хочете зі мною займатися карате,
добре, тепер давайте трохи потренуємося
ось перше речення
виберіть правильний варіант, варіанти
будуть однаковими. Іди, грай добре, я
плаваю,
чи помічаєш ти, що закінчується, якщо так, то
твоя відповідь очевидна, це йди Вау,
цікаво,
добре, давайте далі, так що наступна
футбольна їжа о, вона є  м'яч, так що це
правильно  це гра, хм,
цей нормальний, добре, тому наступна
рибалка знову дивиться Шінг, я G, так
що він використав би правильно, іди Ден приходить, люди займаються
аеробікою, вони
знають, що миша не може зробити це сама.
хлопці, давайте продовжуємо добре
гольф гольф м'яч гра змагання,
так що грайте правильно, ви добре, ще
одна гімнастика, знову гімнастика
ні, я G добре, але іноді м'яч, але
це не гра, тоді
вам потрібно, вони роблять гімнастику
добре  і люди не крикет, хто грає в
крикет,
можливо, англієць добре, так що крикет
знову чаша і гра, і,
звичайно, ви граєте добре, так що давайте рухатися
далі і легка атлетика легка атлетика без м'ячів
я можу зробити це сам, тому це означає, що зроблено правильно,
зроби тоді  100% лайфхак, якщо це
OMG, це також іду і останній, я сподіваюся,
і регбі, регбі, боул і, звичайно,
це гра, і ми змагаємося один з
одним, і це гра, правильно ви зробили
чудову роботу, ви готові рухатися  добре,
так що подивіться на ці пропозиції  ces який
твій улюблений вид спорту як часто ти в
нього граєш хмм подивись у яку гру вони
грають ти віддаєш перевагу грати чи
дивитися спорт і привіт, мамо, я не можу зараз говорити,
вибачте, я жартую, я говорю
про сьогодення у всьому  ці шанси сина,
але те, що іноді я кажу, я
жартую,
а іноді я кажу, як часто ти
граєш у це, яка різниця, добре,
давайте влаштуємо граматичну боротьбу, тож у лівому кутку у
нас є присутній простий підбадьорюй для
теперішнього простого, а в правому  кут
із Божим теперішнім безперервним, яка
різниця,
давайте посваритися так теперішнє просте
теперішнє просте ми використовували для загальних фактів
і правди, наприклад англійська любов до
футболу, це факт
, це правда, тоді ми використовуємо його для звичок
і рутин, це означає для дій, які ми робимо
кожен день або зазвичай або часто або
іноді рідко або навіть ніколи це
рутина, вони грають у футбол кожен день
, зворотний відлік іде розклади чи
програми Чемпіонат світу починається в червні Я
можу не писати я не великий фанат
футб  все, але я сподіваюся, що це почнеться в червні
добре, це був учасник з їхнього
лівого кута, зараз просто
, хлопці, якщо вам потрібно записати це,
знайдіть кілька хвилин, щоб зробити це ще раз
факти та загальні звички правди та
рутини графіки та програми зараз
давайте подивимося на другого
учасника, теперішнє безперервне і
поточне продовження використовується для дій, які
відбуваються зараз або приблизно під час
розмови подивіться вони грають у футбол
звідки я знаю, що це відбувається зараз у мене
є дієслово look it також може бути
послухай, тоді я можу використовувати зараз або на
даний момент завершено
ми використовуємо теперішнє безперервну увагу для
фіксованих майбутніх домовленостей цікаво,
чому це сьогодення для майбутнього так,
все можливо з англійською,
подивіться на приклад, коли грати у
футбол з пропущеним у суботу
це  діяльність зафіксована і влаштована ми
називаємо це міфом ми запросили їх або вони
запросили нас прийти, і ми вирішили
пограти у футбол наступної суботи, і
ми кажемо, що граємо в фу  тбол зі Смітом у
суботу, тоді, якщо я хочу когось критикувати,
і мені потрібно завжди говорити,
тому що мене дратує чиясь
поведінка, я буду використовувати поточний безперервний -
наприклад, о він завжди грає в
теніс, о він завжди приходить пізно, о
він завжди говорить неправду  він не повинен
бути обдуреним з цим завжди для
критики ми все ще використовуємо Present
Continue ви готові потренуватися,
давайте спробуємо добре, так що перевірте, подивіться
на речення, і ви повинні використовувати
Present Simple або Present Continue,
тому першим важкоатлет чекає
три години щодня кожен день, це
рутина, тому правильна відповідь: підйоми.
Зауважте, що підняття закінчуються,
тому що важкоатлет — це він, вона або це.
Боулі це, можливо, він чи вона насправді,
тоді друге речення подивіться на тих хлопців з
мечами, якщо я скажу  подивіться правильно, це
дія відбувається зараз, тому
правильна відповідь: ці хлопці
фехтують мечами, добре,
наступний у стрільбі з лука лучник, на якого я ціляюсь, стріляючи
з лука і стріли
дуже модний вид спорту, і
це факт, що
точки є правдою, тому ми використовуємо правильну
теперішню просту стрілянину і знову звертаємо увагу на
кінцівку s, бо він/вона/воно
потім приходить, коли гарна погода.
Я зазвичай на своєму вітрильнику, яка чудова
рутина правильно
яка чудова звичка, тому що це зазвичай буває,
а правильна відповідь - правильно
вітрило зроблено бігуни, які
найшвидші, завжди виграють бігу бігуни,
які це буває завжди, це факт правильно,
хто спринт найшвидший, завжди виграє
гонку добре
добре, хлопці  баскетболіст
м'яч і одночасно біг він
бігає, і він правильний дриблінг, він
веде м'яч, і він
одночасно біжить добре, коні зараз немає
ніяких виправдань, просто присутні безперервно,
звичайно, хоча коні зараз бігають риссю
вони чекають, поки гонка
почнеться добре наступний, щоб почати
гру тенісист м'яч це
правило це факт
, це правда, просто подає
м'яч добре ще двоє, тому я мій гірський
велосипед  завтра в гонці на гірських велосипедах
завтра, можливо, робить фіксовану домовленість,
тому для фіксованих деяких домовленостей
зазвичай використовують правий теперішній безперервний Я
катаюся на своєму гірському велосипеді завтра в гонці на
гірських велосипедах і останній
іноді діти один з одним
грають іноді це  рутина, це
звичка, тому іноді діти борються
один з одним занадто туго, я чекаю, коли
ви прийдете до мого наступного уроку, побачимось, хлопці
[Музика]
ви